et
notre invité politique sont châtains
sont sans doute vaut son bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
économiste membre d'europe écologie les
verts est candidate aux législatives à
paris on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse régionale représentée par
stéphane bern est de ouest france
bonjour stéphane bonjourbonjour un chat
et sandrine rousseau toujours pas
d'union à gauche l'accord n'est toujours
pas trouvé alors il a été trouvé entre
les insoumis les écologistes et les
communistes mais ça discute toujours
évidemment avec les socialistes à des
points de blocage c'est ce qu'ils disent
est ce que vous croyez vraiment qu'un
accord va être possible ah oui je pense
qu'il va être possible je pense qu'il va
aboutir et je pense qu'on n'a jamais été
aussi près de la voir évidemment jours
qu'on attend ça mais très bien mais sauf
que savait millions de da gauche ça fait
15 ans qu'on essaye de le faire on n'a
jamais réussi à le faire là on a réussi
à le faire avancer beaucoup en dix jours
laissez nous encore quelques heures
enfin voilà aujourd'hui puisque manuel
bompard les la france a soumis disait
qu'il fallait impérativement que ce soit
conclue hier oui bah après je ne sais
pas quel est l'état des rapports de
force mais en tous les cas oui là il
faut qu'on aille en campagne et puis
surtout qu'on annonce à
son ils sont trop gourmands les
socialistes en fait ils demandent trop
par rapport aux scores qu'ils ont fait à
la présidentielle allez je vais pas
donner des bons points et les mauvais
points surtout que m et filles
et aussi durant négociations l'équipe
peut être vécu
et viennent donc voilà j'ai évidemment
dans ce dans ces moments là il ya
toujours des tensions il ya toujours des
demandes qui sont plus importantes des
réponses qui sont plus faibles mais
l'accord est compliqué à trouver entre
insoumis écologie oui ça a été compliqué
et plusieurs fois on l'a annoncé et puis
finalement on a eu plusieurs jours après
donc eh bien si la conscription c'est
pas mal quand même pour vous vous avez
bien négocier bien négocié autre affaire
mais je pense qu'à la fin on atterrit
sur quelque chose qui est qui est
raisonnable et qui est respectueux après
100 circonscription quand on a quand il
y en a 5 177 et aussi d'humour e pour un
parti politique il faut bien se rendre
compte de ça et c'est pour ça que moi je
dis aux électeurs et électrices que oui
on va la faire l'union à gauche 1 on a
compris le message du 1er tour on l'a
enfin compris j'ai envie de dire ça y
est on va la faire en a entendu vous
voulez absolument qu'on gagne aussi on
veut gagner avec vous on a des devoirs
et des droits vis-à-vis de vous car on a
des devoirs sur tout et donc on vous a
entendu maintenant il faut aussi
comprendre que ce sont des choses qui
sont douloureuses en interne des
formations politiques et donc voilà il
faut aussi baisser le temps il faut pas
s'impatienter chaque chose en son temps
mais on va y arriver et douloureuse chez
vous bien sûr c'est une division dans
l'école on me vous veniez vous venez
d'en parler mais en bretagne on n'y a
aucune circonscription alors qu'il y
avait un très bon score aux régionales
alors que iliad a vu les corps et la
partie exactement donc bon tout ça il
faut une en or c'est pareil moi qui
viens du nord c'est c'est une
catastrophe mans mais de fait on a
préféré vraiment aller vers à l'accord
et répondre à la demande des citoyens et
citoyennes qui s'est exprimée dans les
urnes le 1er tour de la présidentielle
alors voilà il faut aussi entendre que
chez nous il ya un petit temps de
convalescence
d'accord tout le monde ne l'acceptent
pas on n'entend pas yannick jadot par
exemple depuis quelques jours ici bien
sûr qu'ils l'acceptent j'imagine
il a du mal avec c'était cet accord vous
en avait parlé avec les noms j'en ai pas
parlé avec lui mais je pense que de
toute façon oui évidemment s'est passé
pas la ligne qui l'a défendue dans la
campagne mais je pense aussi qu'il n'a
entendu le message des électeurs et est
ce que vous craignez que selon le score
aux législatives puisque évidemment vous
visez la majorité mais vous n'êtes pas
sûr de l'obtenir est ce que selon le
score législatives il peut y avoir une
secousse un retour de bâton sur cet
accord qui peut faire exploser certains
partis dont le nôtre non je pense que ce
qui ce qui n'aurait ce qu'il aurait fait
exploser c'est de ne pas faire l'accord
mais il rompt le voit ça a été voté à 82
% chez nous c'est énorme vu des
sacrifices que sa demande c'est énorme
82 % c'est le cas chez vous chez celle
où au sein du parti socialiste c'est
quand même ça a l'air d'être quand même
très différent là il ya un vrai risque
d'implosion oui mais je pense que c'est
évidemment c'est facile de dire ça
depuis la place où je suis mais je pense
que c'est aussi une forme de
clarification de la ligne du parti
socialiste est quelque part peut-être
que là c'est là au ciné l'espoir de la
gauche parce que finalement cette frange
du parti socialiste qui refusait tout
tout
tout pas vers la gauche qui a refusé des
réformes sociales importantes qui ne
s'est jamais engagé sur l'écologie aussi
fortement qu'on que le l'urgence
l'exigent
qui sont hi fi représentait france oui
je pense wilate r saison du blocage pour
vous moi je pense que c'est l'un des
artisans principaux du blocage et je
pense même que c'est un des artisans du
fait que la gauche soit ans et demi
était comme elle l'est comme elle l'a
été pour la première pour la
présidentielle ou par les clarifications
vous dit qu'il s'en aille c'est ce que
disait olivier faure il ya quelques
jours qu'ils partent donc que bernard
cazeneuve par exemple 10 en cas d'accord
moi je quitterais parti socialiste qui
est une partie des militants ou des
cartes qu'ils s'en aillent pour vous ça
fait partie de cette qualification c'est
pas un problème c'est même quelque chose
que j'étais bien mais qui reste un fait
mais s'ils veulent partir qui partent un
moment ils peuvent pas tout bloquer ils
peuvent pas tout bloquer bloquer une
renaissance de la gauche ils ne peuvent
pas bloquer une recomposition à gauche
et on peut pas imaginer que ce soit la
déchéance de nationalité les lois
travail et ses acquis un droit de veto
sur ce qui se passe à gauche aujourd'hui
ce serait injuste ce serait pas à la
hauteur des enjeux et par ailleurs je
rappelle quand même que l'objectif
principal de cette union c'est que jean
luc mélenchon soit premier ministre et
que surtout on protège la vie des
français deux des réformes libérales
d'emmanuel macron c'est un enjeu est
vraiment il ya des gens qui vont manger
ou pas manger il ya des gens qui vont
travailler ou pas travailler à cause de
ces réformes libérales donc là
maintenant il faut vraiment concours à
cet accord c'était fait parmi les choses
qui bloque ya évidemment la répartition
des circonscriptions ça ça fait partie
des négociations ses fans le disait vous
en avez obtenu une centaine est ce que
vous en êtes prêt vous êtes prêts ont
laissé certaines au parti socialiste
pour que l'accord se fasse mais nous on
a déjà signé donc là on
enfin déjà signal sur un accord oui mais
après ça c'est les filles au ps de se
mettre d'accord c'est ce que j'avais dit
au
négociateur chez nous je leur avais dit
photo p en premier je pense que c'est sa
passion l'a fait confortable et c'est ce
qu'on a fait et je pense que cette
récession n'est pas d'accord une fille
née entre le parti socialiste et les
autres forces de gauche est-ce que la
corde ensemble a encore du sens est-ce
que vous avez négocié avec le je pense
mais je suis sûr qu'il y aura un accord
et d'ailleurs je salue le travail
incroyable qui est fait par olivier faur
qui quand même tient la barre malgré les
vents contraires malgré les secousses
malgré les coups de pression malgré les
coups de menton et respect à lui quoi
les efforts mais il a un désaccord
principal c'est la question de l'europe
ne veut pas que le terme de
désobéissance retraités figurent dans
cet accord est ce qu il a raison
je pense qu'on est déjà en situation
désobéissante on l'a vu pendant la crise
du coc vide les traités qui sont les
plus contestés sont est traité qui nous
imposait d'avoir 3 % de déficit
budgétaire et pas plus et d'avoir 80 %
d'endettement du pays et fait 80 % du
pib d'endettement et pas plus là on a
déjà explosé ça donc en fait on est déjà
en situation d obéissance donc la
question c'est comment on adapte la
réalité les traités à la réalité 2 la
situation économique des pays
aujourd'hui oui il faut les revoir alors
est-ce qu'il faut les revoir dans le
cadre d'une désobéissance ou est-ce
qu'il faut les revoir dans le cadre
d'une coalition différentes de simples
couple franco allemand dans l'europe
c'est la question mais
c'est pas la même chose vous êtes
d'accord ben oui mais de fait on
désobéit on est en situation d
obéissance 1 donc c'est une réalité
roule donc pour ce thème n'est pas un
problème non hier clémentine autain qui
est peut être à votre place elle nous
disait pour clarifier également la
situation sur ce sujet entre il n'est
pas question d'une sortie immédiate de
l'union européenne à l'adie immédiate
est ce que vous craignez de vous êtes
engagé dans un projet qui cache autre
chose et qui amènerait à terme à une
sortie de l'union européenne mais nous
ne participerons pas à la sortie d'une
union européenne et c'est en ça aussi
que c'est une coalition et qu'il y a des
différences et qu'il y aura des groupes
différents à l'assemblée nationale ça
veut ça veut dire qu'à la fin on a des
des convergences et qu'on a des
objectifs communs mais s'il s'agit de
sortir de l'union européenne des
écologistes s'opposent roi cela voilà
dans l'est parmi des points falloir
discuter entre ou parce que vous n'êtes
pas forcément d'accord sur tout bien
évidemment il ya le nucléaire est-ce que
ça ça fait partie des choses qui peuvent
achoppé notamment avec le communiste
cabine des positions très différentes
des vôtres mais les communistes ont
accepté dans l'accord l'idée de la
sortie du nucléaire donc
estimant référendum est ce que vous êtes
favorable à un référendum sur cette
question pour que ça soit tranchée par
le club donc je pense que la sortie du
nucléaire ça faisait partie des points
forts du programme de jean luc mélenchon
lors de la présidentielle nous nous
sommes pour la sortie du nucléaire donc
ça fait une majorité au sein de cette
coalition et que donc non il faut une
fouille est né là donc ça va les
communistes doivent se ranger qui eux
sont depuis très longtemps opposée est
un grand défenseur du nucléaire vous me
dites sur cette question ils doivent se
ranger derrière où ils ont accepté
l'accord là ils ont accepté la sortie du
nucléaire faut se souvenir quand même
que le nucléaire là on est en situation
de sécheresse extrême déjà un dans une
partie du pays en france faire du des
centrales nucléaires le long de le nom
de fleuves dont le niveau baisse et qui
sont soumis à la sécheresse ça n'est pas
raisonnable on en a discuté avec jean
luc mélenchon quand on s'est retrouvés
par hasard dans un café après la manif
du 1er mai mais celui-là c'est la raison
voilà donc oui on va sortir du nucléaire
et oui on à londres il ya la question du
mal à emmener à la question de la
manière dont on y sort du nucléaire
au moment où on présentera cette
question de sortie du nucléaire est
peut-être que les communistes votre
rencontre et bien voilà ça fait partie
de ces mots de ces de ces lieux où on a
le droit de ne pas être d'accord sur
tout et si on était d'accord sur tout on
n'aurait pas toute l'histoire de la
gauche telle qu'on l'a actuellement et
de l'écologie oui nous avons des
formations politiques différentes oui
nous avons des sociologies différentes
oui nous avons des histoires différentes
et bien c'est cela qui fait notre
richesse et c'est l'addition de toutes
c'est de toutes ces histoires de toutes
ces mobilisations qui va faire qu'on va
gagner cette majorité à l'assemblée
nationale donc n'ayons pas peur de ces
différences au contraire c'est ce qui
fait notre richesse et oui on aura droit
de s'émanciper sur tel ou tel point très
bien ça fait partie aussi de la richesse
de la guerre moi c'est un petit peu dur
à comprendre la compréhension mais si
vous êtes en train de vous dire que
finalement l'accord il est valable pour
gagner ces législatives permettre
d'avoir jean luc mélenchon au premier
ministre c'est ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure et que finalement si vous avez
des divergences sur le fond après sa
nasse et chacun pourra reprendre son
agenda ses positions
ça veut dire que c'est parce que je fais
j'ai compris
que l'alliance elle durera pas au-delà
durera l alliance durera pendant pendant
tout le mandat et l'alliance durera
parce que nous avons des objectifs en
commun que ses objectifs c'est la
retraite à 60 ans que ses objectifs
c'est d'augmenter le smic et les bas
salaires que cet objectif c'est de faire
des revenus d'autonomie que cet objectif
c'est de revoir les conditions de
travail c'est pas qu'une question de
retraite à 60 ans c'est faire en sorte
qu'on ne soit plus le pays d'europe où
il ya le plus de morts au travail on est
le pays d'europe où il ya le plus de
morts au travail on est le pays d'europe
qui reconnaissons le moins la pénibilité
au travail donc c'est cela que c'est sûr
ça qu'on va se mettre d'accord c'est
nous sommes nous avons absolument besoin
de données mais un coup d'accélérateur
immense à la transformation écologique
mais les derniers on est les derniers en
matière de d'énergie renouvelable c'est
cela que l'on crée c'est cet espoir là
que l'on va amener jusqu'à l'assemblée
nationale et au gouvernement est
vraiment ce sera un changement sur la
retraite à 60 ans parce qu'évidemment ça
servirait ce les gens ça les inquiète
aussi aidé à la retraite à 60 ans mais
il ya quarante annuités aussi dans ce
que veut la france insoumise et donc ce
que vous avez signé ça veut dire qu'au
fond concrètement il n'y a pas beaucoup
de personnes qui pourront partir
réellement à 60 ans à la retraite mais
il ya toutes les personnes qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt oui mais
c'est que les personnes qui nous
écoutent comprennent bien cette histoire
d'âge de la retraite parce qu'en fait à
chaque fois qu'on augmente l'âge de
départ à la retraite on crée de
l'injustice et pas de la petite
injustice de l'énorme injustice c'est à
dire que toutes les personnes qui ont
commencé à travailler très jeunes à 16
ans à 18 ans c'est à dire les personnes
qui ont aussi eu souvent les emplois les
plus pénibles ceux où le corps est le
plus abîmé ceux qui sont le plus exposés
aux produits chimiques à des à des
nuisances type du bruit etc eh bien ces
personnes là en fait doivent travailler
bien plus longtemps que des cadres qui
ont quitté l'université après un bac + 5
donc en fait à chaque fois qu'on décale
l'âge de la retraite on met la santé de
ces gens là en danger c'est la fédé
désormais prises en compte
je vous dis que dans la réforme des
retraites il faut voir et l'âge et les
critères de pénibilité qui ont été
d'ailleurs massacrés par emmanuel macron
durant le mandat de vélizy face ne
tiendra pas compte de la pénibilité dans
la prochaine réforme qui dit qui aura
une sorte d'individualisation en
fonction des gens mais le match a alors
qu'ils soient première sa première
mesure ça a été de supprimer des
critères de bébés-médicaments tiendra
pas compte de la pénibilité
des trucs et après il fait exactement
l'inversé et en l'occurrence sur la
pénibilité alors qu'il y avait eu des
avancées durant le mandat de françois
hollande pour le coup et dieu sait que
je suis quand même pas tendre avec le
frein le mandat de françois hollande
mais sur la pénibilité il y avait eu des
avancées c'est emmanuel macron qui a
tout cassé donc là dessus aucune
confiance 0 confiance et d'ailleurs ça
fait partie des message que j'envoie aux
électeurs électricien ne croyez rien de
ce qui va être dit par emmanuel macron
maintenant on ne croyait rien parce
qu'il nous a systématiquement fait le
coup en 2017 il nous a fait le coup du
vice-premier ministre en charge de la
transition écologique qui s'appelait
nicolas hulot c'était une figure ça
devait être un poids lourd du
gouvernement il a démissionné tellement
il n'arrivait pas avant c'est donc en
fait
chargé de l'écologie et qui fera de
l'écologie une priorité vous n'y croyez
pas absolument pas parce qu'en fait pour
ça il faut il faut comprendre il faut
croire à aux mesures qu'il faut mener et
il faut comprendre la question du
réchauffement climatique et de la perte
de biodiversité de la vie de jay des
cycles de l'ofa de l'ensemble de la
question écologique on l'a vu lors du
débat de l'entre-deux tours avec marine
le pen y en avait pas un des deux qui
avait lu le rapport du giec c'est le
défi majeur c'est le défi majeur c'est
un défi inouï dire que jamais l'humanité
n'a été confronté à un tel défi en temps
de paix eh bien il n'avait pas lu ça et
il est président de la république donc
pardon mais là non moi je ne crois rien
de ces grands mots les grands mots on a
déjà eu là aujourd'hui maintenant il
faut passer aux grandes actions et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut un gouvernement de
coalition de gauche et écologistes
doutent et du président la république
des manades maquereau en la matière mais
s'ils choisissaient un premier ministre
ou une première ministre qui était
parfaitement adapté ce que vous évoquez
serre qu'ils connaissent parfaitement
ces questions là qui est une vraie
volonté de sa part de faire avancer une
planification écologique et la
transition est ce que ça vous pensez que
ça pourrait être compatible si vous
seriez rassurer ma matière de fait ils
n'en trouvent pas et de fait il a
visiblement passé beaucoup télé de coups
de téléphone et ils n'en trouvent pas et
pourquoi ils n'en sont
annoncés pas été appelé moi
cette idée là je pense que
c'est pas la peine qu'ils les mots sur
l'accord donc on a bien compris qu'il y
aurait une sorte de coalition au sein de
l'assemblée nationale si évidemment vous
remportez la majorité peut-être si vous
ne l'a remportée pas aussi vous
gouvernerait ensemble de toute façon
même si vous avez une opposition est ce
que vous dites que cette union des
gauches à l'assemblée elle doit aussi se
faire au sénat est-ce qu'il faut revoir
aussi la manière de travailler des
groupes parlementaires au sénat ou pas
je pense que le message qui a été envoyé
par les électeurs et électrices au
premier tour de la présidentielle
c'est maintenant on veut que vous gagnez
on veut pas que vous fassiez bonne
figure on veut pas que vous ayez de bons
scores on veut pas que vous soyez
respectueux des identités de chacun on
veut que vous gagnez c'est ça le message
du premier tour donc il faut gagner il
faut gagner à l'assemblée nationale il
faut gagner au sénat alors le sénat il
va y avoir des sénatoriales dans voilà
mais il va falloir que on est des
majorités qui nous permettent d'emporter
de gagner des choses est de faire en
sorte que la vie des gens que sauf que
là juste sur le mode de scrutin des
législatives
évidemment l'abstention est là un grand
rôle dans ce mode de scrutin puisqu'il
c12 et demi pour cent des inscrits qu'il
faut faire du coup et vous y avoir
énormément de duels au second tour est
ce que vous ne craignez pas que jean luc
mélenchon soit un peu un repoussoir pour
des électeurs aient l'air et à l'erreur
mais que vous perdiez ses duels qui est
un sorte de front anti candidat de
l'union populaire de fait il n'a pas été
repoussée moi j'ai entendu jean luc
mélenchon repoussoir depuis des mois et
des mois et de fait à la présidentielle
n'a pas été repoussé au rouge oui mais
moi je l gevrey et plus largement mais
je les plains de personnes qui me disait
il ya quelques mois jamais je voterai
jean luc mélenchon et qui ont voté jean
luc mélenchon au titre du fait qu'ils
nous voulait qu'on gagne donc je suis de
gauche mais même du centre même vraiment
du centre du centre gauche est ce que je
dis aux électeurs et électrices de la
droite et du et
qui sont très opposés aux réformes macro
c'est de dire attention là en fait le
seul moyen de ne pas avoir mâcon c'est
de voter pour nous aujourd'hui donc
venez fait lequel est lequel et le bâton
qui fera battre macron c'est nous donc
maintenant voter vous vous dites non est
ce que j'arrive mélenchon il doit
arriver avec son affiche et les émois
premier ministre et faire une affiche un
peu plus groupé pour moins faire juste
jean luc mélenchon qu'on va faire
hégémonie qu'est ce que vous lui
demander de changer cette affiche déjà
afficher tous les partis de gauche mais
déjà je trouve que cette affiche elle
avait le mérite d'être très clair et
d'envoyer un message très clair cm oui
c'est mélenchon premier ministre et ça
enfin on va pas faire semblant que c'est
autre chose donc oui c'est mélenchon
c'est jean luc mélenchon premier
ministre maintenant oui aussi il faut
une autre affiche avec plus de personnes
de subir un autre scénario possible
c'est qu'on est une partition de
l'assemblée en trois comme comme au
niveau du là du premier tour de la
présidentielle trois blocs imaginons que
le centre finalement et le bloc
principal mais n'est pas la majorité
absolue et qui puisse y avoir une
opposition qui s'impose en faisant
coalition est ce que vous seriez prêt
par exemple à négocier c'est
envisageable entre ce grand bloc de
gauche vous êtes en train de constituer
et la droite pour faire barrage pour
faire barrage aux à la majorité
présidentielle
moi j'envisage à je fais pas de
politique fiction de cette nature ce que
je dis c'est que là il nous la majorité
je pense que c'est très possible parce
qu'en plus je pense que la configuration
politique
nous est plutôt favorable et je pense
qu'il y à une telle colère dans la
population y compris de personnes qui ne
sont pas forcément aller voter la
dernière fois mais qui se disent bon ben
là c'est à portée de main et on va aller
voter et donc je crois que vraiment il
le chemin et que l'on gagne et que l'on
gagne le gouvernement imposer une
cohabitation à emmanuel macron et faire
en sorte qu'il n'est pas les mains
libres et qu'il n'est pas cet espèce de
toute puissance dont il assure abusé
pendant tout le mandat juste parce que
le temps file santos au sur une autre
actualité le 16 mai éric hull le maire
écologiste de grenoble va soumettre à
son conseil municipal un nouveau
règlement pour les piscines de sa ville
pour y autoriser le burqini lui 17 ans
mon sujet qui devrait être vu comme un
progrès social est ce que vous partagez
ça mais c'est à mon sujet et si en
france on a on a vraiment cet art
consommé de trouver que l'habit des
femmes quel que soit cet ami est un
sujet politique majeur ou la mbc1
habillé comme un autre là-bas et ça
c'est un avis qui évidemment c'est un
habit de messages mais est-ce que c'est
plus ce que c'était mieux de leur
interdire la piscine est-ce que c'est
mieux de laisser enfermer chez elles
parce qu'elles n'ont pas le droit
d'avoir accès à la piscine ou est-ce que
c'est mieux de le rouvrir la piscine est
de faire en sorte qu'elles aient accès
au sport ou loisir à rencontrer d'autres
personnes et à l'émancipation
moi je suis toujours pour l'émancipation
des femmes partout tout le temps et le
burkina non c'est parce que j'ai dit que
aller à la piscine est un outil
d'émancipation même si vous êtes en mai
laurent wauquiez le président de la
région lui dit qu'il coupera les
subventions si jamais et erik cole et la
majorité municipale vote vote cette
décision vous comprenez non jeu non
seulement je comprends pas mais je pense
que c'est un acte d'autorité est un acte
dangereux parce qu'à partir du moment où
on regarde on en est à regarder les
règlements piscine année qui sont quand
même de la responsabilité des maires et
uniquement des mères on est dans un abus
de pouvoir est vraiment moi j'en ai
enfin j'en ai vraiment marre marre marre
que ce soit le l'habit des femmes qui
soient non stop qui fasse non-stop
l'actualité politique ne s'est pas la
première fois qu'il ya des décisions des
mr écolo vous le savez qu'il suscite des
débats des polémiques est ce que vous
pensez que ça vous a coûté des voix à la
présidentielle cette écologie municipa
mais l'écologie c'est quelque chose qui
de toute façon systématiquement suscite
le débat voire la risée voir la moquerie
de fait quand on contient un maire
écologiste qui a dit qu'il ne voulait
pas du
tour de france parce que c'était
finalement une caravane qui était bien
trop importante de la pollution etc eh
bien on a réussi à changer ça rien que
par cette décision c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui le tour de france a fait
des efforts conséquents qu'il n'avait
jamais fait avant et d'une ampleur qu'il
n'avait jamais fait avant pour modifier
ça quand on disait qu'il ne fallait pas
que signé des femmes potiche qui fasse
la bise à des coureurs une fois qu'ils
arrivent eh bien ça a été modifié donc
je dis oui on peut se moquer de
l'écologie et on peut rire de nous sauf
que à un moment donné finalement le fait
de poser sa sur la table eh bien ça
change des choses et c'est ça l'écologie
c'est que ça change les choses la
patience des fans est ce qu'europe
écologie les verts va se déconstruire se
reconstruire après la présidentielle
après les séquences qu'on est en train
de vivre est question annexe est ce que
vous serez candidat pour prendre la tête
du parti au prochain congrès je pense
que l'écologie doit
tirer le bilan de la séquence bien sûr
comme n'importe quelle partie d'ailleurs
à l'entrejambe bien sûr je pense que
c'est déjà en cours et que finalement
cet accord avait qualifié déjà une forme
de réponse à ce qui s'est passé et puis
après moi vous savez je mène j'ai mené
beaucoup de combats dans ma vie j'ai
mené des combats qui étaient parfois
extrêmement dur et je sais une chose de
ces combats c'est qu'on ne mène jamais
l'étape suivante avant celle qui se
présente celle qui se présente la série
législatives et j'irai jusqu'au bout
mais vous ne voulez pas que ça soit
l'étape suivante de prendre la tête du
parti aujourd'hui ce sont les
législatives
et l'idée de gagner la majorité de ce
pays merci beaucoup sandrine rousseau
merci d'avoir été notre invité à la une
de ouest france loyers en pot retraite
qu'à l'impact de l'inflation c'est à la
une de votre journal fait femmes merci
son gré
[Musique]